in the United States today we know our
system of government so well that it
hardly bears thinking about we know that
there's a president who's the head of
the executive branch
there's Congress which is made up of the
House of Representatives in the Senate
and there's the judicial branch which
has the Supreme Court as its head of a
whole court system that stretches
throughout the United States but how did
the United States end up with this
system we frequently forget that the
Constitutional Convention which created
this system we know today happened in
1787 that was more than a decade after
the Declaration of Independence so there
was this eleven year plus period before
the United States had its modern-day
Constitution and during that time fought
the Revolutionary War one in 1783 and
tried out a completely different system
of government called the Articles of
Confederation which we talked a little
bit more about in another video
now the Articles of Confederation had a
very strong sense of limited government
in fact you could think of the Articles
of Confederation as being a little bit
more like a loose confederation of
states where each state had one vote in
the legislative branch the branch that
makes laws and they had to really agree
on most things 9 out of 13 for most
legislation and unanimous agreement for
any kind of amendments to this system
and I think it's clear why the founders
first went with this system of limited
government because they had just
revolted against a monarchy they thought
of the states as being in what they call
just kind of a league of friendship it
almost see it as being similar to the
European Union today independent nations
who do some things together for foreign
policy reasons and
Nanak reasons but by the late 1780s it
was becoming clear that the Articles of
Confederation were not working with such
a weak central government it was really
hard to get things done they couldn't
raise taxes they couldn't raise a
military some states were even putting
taxes on the goods of other states so in
1787 delegates from 12 of the 13 states
Rhode Island did not participate because
Rhode Island was not a big fan of
central government came together in
Philadelphia in the same place where
they had signed the Declaration of
Independence to think about how to
revise the Articles of Confederation
when some very notable figures were
there George Washington was one of them
see Ben Franklin over here and James
Madison although some people that you
might have expected to be at the
Constitutional Convention were not
namely Thomas Jefferson and John Adams
who were out of the country being
diplomats at the time so the delegates
at the Constitutional Convention have a
pretty difficult problem to solve they
want to have a stronger central
government one that can get things done
make sure the states play well together
raise armies raise taxes but they don't
want a central government that is too
strong because they just escaped from
monarchy they don't want to recreate
monarchy in the United States so they're
looking for a very delicate balance of a
government strong enough to get things
done but not so strong as to promote
tyranny now even though the delegates
were supposed to be revising the
Articles of Confederation some people
had in secret been considering
completely throwing out the Articles of
Confederation and starting anew but one
of the biggest hurdles they had to solve
was what would a new sort of legislature
look like so the Virginia delegates
suggested a plan for the legislature
it's the law
making body that would be bicameral
means to room or to house from by
meaning to and camara
the Latin for room and their idea was
that there would be a lower house
similar to the House of Commons in
English Parliament that would be
directly elected because individuals
would vote for the representatives but
the number of Representatives that each
state would get would be decided by
their population now Virginia was the
largest state by population by far and
so this plan would have worked out
pretty well for them because they would
have gotten the largest proportion of
Representatives small states like
Delaware and Georgia Rhode Island would
have very few representatives indeed
comparatively they also wanted to have
an upper house similar to the House of
Lords in the British Parliament which
would be appointed by state legislatures
but just like the lower house the number
of Representatives would also be
determined by population now as you can
imagine the small states were not big
fans of having representation based just
on population so they came back with a
different plan this was called the New
Jersey plan so the little states that
all right the Virginia plan gives way
too much power to the big states we want
an equal voice in legislation so the New
Jersey Plan much like the Articles of
Confederation gave one vote to each of
the states so that the small states
would have the same representation in
Congress as the large states and their
plan was for a single chamber or eunuch
Merl legislature so this really wasn't
much different from the Articles of
Confederation at all so how did the
delegates resolve this issue of how to
balance the voices of large states with
large populations with small states that
had small populations because in a
situation where all states have an equal
number of votes like in the New Jersey
plan the 60,000 residents of Delaware
could have as much say as the almost
700,000 residents of Virginia meaning
that the people who lived in Delaware
were in effect more powerful but at the
same time you wouldn't want it so that
people living in the larger states could
get their way all the time what if the
people in Delaware had a very legitimate
concern that those in Virginia didn't
share it would be impossible to get all
of these states to agree to amend or
replace the Articles of Confederation if
some of them felt like their interests
weren't being taken into account at all
so to solve this issue of how to wait
the representation of the states the
delegates came up with what's called the
great compromise or sometimes the
Connecticut compromise and in a way what
they did was combine these two plans
they made a legislative branch that was
bicameral to house with a lower and an
upper house and this lower house become
the House of Representatives where each
state would have representatives in
proportion to their population so states
that have large populations have more
representatives states with small
populations have fewer representatives
and those representatives would be
directly elected by the people now and
this time the people was a fairly
small proportion to vote in the 1790s
you had to be a white man with fairly
significant property so it wasn't full
suffrage
it wasn't even full suffrage for white
men but these folks were elected by vote
then this upper house would be the
Senate and in the Senate each state
would have two senators regardless of
their size so that as legislation moved
through Congress
first from the lower house where it
would be approved and if approved sent
to the upper house they're all states
would have an equal voice in whether
legislation was passed and in this upper
house the Senators would not be directly
elected but rather appointed by state
legislatures and in fact senators were
appointed into the twentieth century now
the great compromise wasn't the only
compromise made at the Constitutional
Convention they made a number more and
we'll talk more about those and about
the other two branches of the government
in the next video